welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
book reviews where I give unvarnished
trustworthy reviews of books in
Practical philosophy and all sorts of
closely connected disciplines such as
professional ethics self-help leadership
the book that we're going to be looking
at today which is by Julian beginning
the great guide what David Hume can
teach us about being human and Living
Well fits really solidly into the
purview of the series and I will tell
you at the beginning that I am
unreservedly recommending this book for
anybody who is interested in
intellectual history in philosophy as a
way of life and David Hume himself and
in philosophy more generally I think
it's really quite a admirable
study here that's doing a lot lot of
different cool things and doing them
quite well this is a pretty recent book
2021 Princeton University press it's
gotten a lot of discussion already but
I'll see if I can add something to it
for you that might help you decide
whether you want to get your hands on
this now you can of course go to a local
library they will probably have a copy
in their newer book section or if you
like you'll find as you if you click the
you know video description or show more
you'll find an Amazon affiliate link
that will lead you to the page for this
book if you buy it I get a little cut so
you're benefiting the channel and my
work as well so I'm going to talk about
a number of different things in this
review and that'll give you a good sense
about what is going on with this kind of
unusual study of David Hume
I like to begin these book reviews by
focusing on what I call the three s's
style structure and summary and maybe we
should start with the summary first what
kind of book is this so it's called the
Great guide and it is you know that's
kind of a good play on words because it
is using David Hume his life and his
thought to actually provide us with a
guide not a complete guide but a partial
guide to how we ought to live and this
goes to a little bit of the structure
this is an unusual book in that it has
an appendix at the end which is titled
human maxims and aphorisms now some of
these are directly from David Hume some
of these are derived or summarized from
hume's work on the part of baggini and
there's there's you know quite a lot of
them here under a bunch of different
rubrics ranging from reason to knowledge
of the world to skepticism and doubt
religion human nature argument and
discussion morality we could go on and
on and on
and these are meant to provide a sort of
way of understanding ourselves and of
Living Well living better trying to make
progress towards that uh something else
that I think is really uh kind of cool
about the book The Way It Is set up so
there's a number of different
chapters they have you know nice big
headings not everything in each chapter
necessarily fits what you would expect
to find in the chapter but it's set up
both chronologically beginning with you
know Hume and his beginnings and ending
with hume's death and his influence to a
certain extent and then looking at all
the other stuff along the way but
introducing thematic topics so you know
Hume is very important for talking about
and providing us with interesting
analyzes and arguments about religion
and what we find is that much of this is
going to be put off until a later
chapter you know we're introduced to
hume's works his travels his occupations
and they all kind of fit together within
the structure of these these chapters
they all also incorporate at certain
points these maxims or aphorisms that
we've talked about already and beginning
will put these into as you can see here
the bold print that you see to set them
apart and Signal them to us
um
it is an intellectual biography so the
job of this kind of text is to not only
tell us about Hume and what he thought
but to provide us with context
historical context you know where does
Hume fit in how is he being influenced
how is he influencing others what sort
of reactions is he provoking what are
his connections with the other people
whether intellectual or economic or
political of the time and the movements
that are happening prime example of this
is the discussion of Hume and his
relationship not just with the Parisian
salons but later on with Jean-Jacques
Rousseau kind of a darling and also uh
you know
polemical figure we'll just say right so
that's that's quite important
um
I think this is you know showing us Hume
not just as an intellectual not just
analyzing his ideas and arguments
but helping us to grasp David Hume as a
person that seems to be one of the
beginnings
um really important intentions but also
strengths in this work
and he does say something quite
interesting and I think this is a good
strategy to use uh he tells us that he
aims to
put you know he says I'm going to use a
lot of hume's own words simply because I
find them so elegantly crafted I can't
see how paraphrasing improves them I
know many people find him difficult to
read because of his 18th century Style
with its long sentences and archaic
vocabulary but Within These seemingly
Meandering and long-winded texts there
are so many gems and and beginning is is
doing an editor's job here picking out
the ones that are going to be most
effective for for us as readers grasping
what is going on with David Hume there
is one other thing I want to bring up
and it's this is very early on as well
this is in his section Scotland's Hidden
Gem he says Hume didn't just write about
how to live he modeled this good life he
was modest in his philosophical
pretensions advocating human sympathy as
much as if not more than human
rationality he avoided hysterical
condemnations of religion and
Superstition as well as overly
optimistic praise for the power of
Science and rationality he exemplified a
way of life that is gentle reasonable
amiable all the things public life now
so rarely is and he goes on he says what
Hume said and did form equal parts of
the harmonious whole a life of the mind
and body that stands as an inspiration
to us all I want to approach David Hume
as a synoptical a person whose
philosophy touches every aspect of how
he lived and who he was so now this
points to to what is going on in the
work to do that I need to approach his
life and work together I have followed
in hume's biographical and sometimes
geographical footsteps to show why we
would be wise to follow in his
philosophical ones too so beginning is
advocating a human
lifestyle a life of the Mind a life of
conviviality a life engaged in one
society and I think that's quite good
and now he mentions following in hume's
geography so there are a few sections in
here and this gets to some of the the
you know style as well as summary where
he is going to tell us about this
following in hume's footsteps so he
actually goes to you know the flesh for
example where not only did Descartes
spend time but um so did Hume
and he says you know uh
he talks about the the different things
that they could do so the current
occupant of Yvonne doe conforms to this
image of the French being interested in
society and conversation not only did
she offer us an impromptu private tour
she gifted us a bottle of wine from The
Vineyard next door
it's not a grand van she said
apologetically merely epitiven we
discovered she was correct when we
opened the bottle of Claude yavendo with
philosopher friends despite being closed
with the champagne cork the wine was a
red and only start a slightly sparkling
so he was talking about this sort of
stuff and he says it's the kind of
pleasant easy drinking rustic wine
that's produced all over Continental
Europe and is probably closer to the
style of wine Hume would have drunk than
the modern stronger varieties right so
it's kind of an interesting little
digression there there's one other I I
had my eye on to bring up with you and
to tell you about from the text
um he is is uh talking about
um you know various matters like
identity and he he tells us you know he
brings up uh football clubs right so
something that
soccer we would say over here
people can relate to thinking about how
matters are put together and so you know
there's there's a lot of little
vignettes like that and there's a lot of
uh pictures in the book as well
um which you might enjoy so I think
that's probably enough about style
structure and summary the last point
that I'll say is it's very readable uh
baggini is a good writer and it's not
only quite readable it's well put
together so what appear to be
digressions almost always turn out to be
connected to the topic under discussion
in ways that are quite helpful and
Illuminating
so what are the main ideas or main
points of this work we've already talked
a little bit about beginning's advocacy
of David hume's thought and life as a
kind of model for us in the 21st century
that we can draw upon despite the
difference in time and culture and even
to some degree language those of us who
are English speakers today don't speak
the language of hume's time right 18th
century England and Scotland right but
there's a lot that we can draw upon and
that is a constant point I think another
thing very big picture that bikini is
bringing before us is that Hume himself
had multiple interests a very broad
um set of of interests he's fairly
omnivorous he will take part in
discussions with all sorts of people
he's not just a philosophical figure but
also writes literary essays engages in
criticism and he even writes a very
important history of England and so he's
he's you know developing all of those
things and why is he doing that bikini
makes a good point you know we tend to
think of philosophers according to the
model of academic philosophers those who
work in colleges and universities intend
to be rather specialized well
that wasn't quite like that back then I
mean there were universities Hume
doesn't get himself a position at the
University of Edinburgh for all sorts of
reasons that you can read about in the
book but he probably did just as well
being outside of the University as he
did within it and that's because of his
broad range of of uh topics that he's
caring about there's a very interesting
discussion early on about like who Hume
is engaging with reading stoics for
example Hume does draw upon them at
certain points but rejects a lot of
their ideas
Renee Descartes and his followers like
Maul brosh we don't read too much in the
present unless we're specializing in
cartesianism or rationalism or 17th
century philosophy Hume is engaged with
these people and and many more as as
well and what he's rejecting is just as
important as what he's advocating or if
not rejecting certainly calling into
question and criticizing
and this leads to another
key topic that I think is really
um Central I agree with bhagini that
this is something key to David Hume he
is calling into question the capacities
of human rationality on its own to
figure things out for us and stressing
the need to pay attention to experience
now this is not an
anti-rationalism saying that reason is
no good but it is a sort of reasonable
take on how much we can rely upon human
reason and so here's uh one discussion
of this
um
he says if Hume seems to be anti-reason
it's only because we've come to assume
that reason is more powerful and more
individualistic than it is interestingly
this more modest and social
understanding has also been given recent
support by cognitive scientists right
and he goes on and says it's not
surprising many fine hume's notion of
reason to flimsy or weak and he goes on
and says philosophers have tended to
exalt reason it's rare to find one so
willing to admit that the tools of their
trade are ill-equipped for the ambition
of their task but Hume is full of Doubt
both in the power of philosophy and in
himself as a Reasoner a little bit later
on we're going to find another good
discussion of this particular point so
he says a great psychological insight is
that although we like to think we're
reasonable people who base our
conclusions on sound arguments a lot of
the time we simply use our intellects to
rationalize what we already believe this
is often thought of as one of modern
psychology's great Revelations but Hume
was there nearly 300 years ago right he
says the passion for philosophy though
it aims at the correction of our manners
and extirpation of our vices it may only
Serve by imprudent management to foster
a predominant inclination and push the
mind with more determined resolution
toward that side which already draws too
much by the bias and propensity of the
natural temper so you know some
important insights there another very
interesting discussion I would say
that's going on in this is of hume's
rejection of there being you know a
essential or core self but it's kind of
a judicious
approach that he says and beginning
notes the very
well with paradoxicality of this he says
consider first the common sense notion
of selfhood to write this book I've
followed in hume's footsteps it seems
obvious that this means tracking the
life and thought of a single person
David Hume who is essentially the same
in Edinburgh Bristol the flesh back in
Britain and Paris and finally back to
Edinburgh again and I was the same
person who started out on this journey
now writing it up in some sense this is
uncontroversial Hume had no problem with
his idea of considering a person the
same over a lifetime as short
autobiography my own life only makes
sense if there was an entire life that
was indeed his nor would he deny that he
made choices
but what he understood myself and choice
were radically different from received
opinion then and now
so he says
um
Hume surely had a card in mind when he
began the section of the trees on
personal identity by saying there are
some philosophers who imagine we are
every moment intimately conscious of
what we call ourself that we feel its
existence and its continuance and
existence and are certain beyond the
evidence of a demonstration both of its
perfect identity and simplicity Hume
however was not so sure for my part when
I enter most intimately into what I call
myself I always stumble on some
particular perception or other of heat
or light or cold or shade uh
love or hatred pain or pleasure I can
never catch myself
at any time without a perception and I
can never observe anything but the
perception so there isn't any uh truly
lasting self according to Hume as we
would think there there is and we're
going to come back to that in just a bit
another great discussion takes place
about Hume and what we call
compatibilism and free will do we
actually have free will with like
capital F capital W Hume thinks nah not
really
um but we do have some measure of choice
and freedom and explaining that is
something quite important what else is
discussed in this the nature of modesty
and whether pride is a good thing or a
bad thing Hume certainly recognizes that
vanity can be problematic but he does
think that pride has been unduly
attacked in in part because of the
contrast with humility which he calls a
Monkish virtue right
um
beginny also says that Hume is really
working on an entire science of human
nature which I think he's quite correct
about and he says that you know many
people really didn't recognize that that
was what Hume is most interested in here
we go
um took a very long time for the
significance of hume's achievements to
be truly recognized mossner laments that
hume's science of human nature was
either ignored or misunderstood by his
own generation and that only in the 20th
century has it met with sympathy and
understanding this might be an
overstatement beginy says but it is
unhappily close to the truth so these
are you know all significant uh ideas
that are being discussed in the work
I'll also mention there's a great
discussion of his connection with
Jean-Jacques Rousseau and there we get
into a lot of drama going on because
Rousseau was a drama Creator we could
say and then we have you know towards
the the middle to the end part a lot of
discussion about hume's views on
religion and miracles Superstition
fanaticism all of these sorts of matters
and I should mention sprinkled
throughout the entire work we do have
these aphorisms and maxims taking the
lessons that we can draw sometimes in
hume's own words from what's going on in
his thought and life and engagements and
turning it into actionable items for us
so that those are some of the main ideas
of this work
I have a lot of good things to say about
this book I can actually say something
that I've said in other places one of
the great ways to complement an author
is the wish that you could have yourself
written a book like this now obviously I
can't do that with David Hume but
perhaps with some other thinkers it's a
great model I think for doing
intellectual biography that will connect
with people's lives and I think this is
a book that you know academics of course
can read and enjoy but non-academic
people I think can get an awful lot out
of this work as well and that's to
beginy's Credit in my view
I'll also say that he's succeeding in
doing several different things right
this is an intellectual biography right
very well researched uh putting things
into their proper contacts and
connecting them together it's all also a
book that I don't want to say self-help
as such but let's call it personal
development and practical ethics that's
going on as well these are coming
together mixed in with other interesting
motifs and bikini is able to bring all
of these matters together in a very well
constructed way so it's quite an
admirable
volume there's some specific discussions
that I think are worth highlighting it's
got a great discussion of Hume on one of
the you know key ideas that we associate
with him the critique of cause and
effect are what we call causality and
you know beginning will tell us
hume's ideas about causation and the
Conformity of past and future are not
simply empty assumptions with no
philosophical justification rather they
are philosophical conclusions with no
logical justification rather instead the
justification comes from experience so
he's making some important distinctions
there and he says we can uh know by
carefully attending the world to the
world that without belief in cause and
effect no reasoning about matters of
fact is possible we know thanks to Hume
that belief in cause and effect is not
justified by reason or observation
custom or habit is
the great guide in human life it is that
principle alone which renders our
experience useful to us and makes us
expect for the future a similar train of
events with those that have appeared in
the past right so this is uh quite good
and and he he talks about
um
what's clear in a reply to an all too
common criticism pressed most clearly in
a review of the treaties
um you know people are saying that that
Hume says anything can happen anything
can lead to any sort of thing and him
says no no it's not quite so simple as
that and beginning is good at sort of
calling this out and showing us how
caricatures of Hume are not really David
Hume there's a very smart analysis I
would say of David Hume on the self and
there is a feature about that which
perhaps you may not find as attractive
as I do but I'm going to read it to you
anyway because as a heavy metal uh lover
since I was a kid it's kind of cool to
see this so he talks about
um thinking about the self the self
changes and beginning says as well as
the proportion of change so too the pace
of change matter others too right and he
says let's give an example consider a
band of the five original members of
Deep Purple when it formed in 1969 only
one is currently in the band there have
been several times when there have been
more acts Deep Purple members in other
bands such as rainbow or White Snake
than there were in Deep Purple itself
yet Deep Purple has an identity as a
single band that changes over time an
identity that is distinct from other
bands its members went on to join great
example one that I particularly like and
I think it's particularly apt as well we
could use other bands of course if
people wanted to look at different ones
another good point that that beginning
is making within is discussion of human
cause on on the self right and
continuity is that we want to
distinguish between identity and
individuation not exactly the same
things there's there's practical
differences between them there's also a
great discussion in there and this is
where the History part is coming in of
the contrast between the French
Enlightenment
or that that Hume is participating in
with the salon culture and meeting these
you know sort of militant atheists right
and the Scottish Enlightenment that
David Hume is an integral part of along
with people like Adam Smith and and many
other others as well and I think this is
quite good because oftentimes people
just talk about the enlightenment as if
it's the same thing everywhere around
the world basically happening in you
know Great Britain and France and to a
certain extent in America primarily in
the New England colonies and then in
Germany but the local differences are
incredibly important right so beginning
is very helpful I think in bringing this
out to us Hume is like many others in
Scotland adopting a more judicious less
radical form of Enlightenment or let's
say style of Enlightenment than the
French philosophs are and the last thing
I want to say about this
so you know we use this term philosophy
as a way of life and you know that's
primarily the the
motto of Pierre Ado although many many
other people have discussed it under
other rubrics you know what alster
McIntyre is doing with tradition
constituting rationality is equally
important now the the maxims that are
derived from hume's own life an example
and from his writings in here are
essentially
providing the skeleton for a human
philosophy as a way of life so without
ever mentioning that term I think that
what bagini is offering us here is
indeed the rudimentary beginnings of a
human philosophy as a way of life which
I I think is a really cool feature of
the work I'm sure it's intentional and
it's something that I I find
particularly compelling about it
with most of the works that I review I
tend to find quite a few matters that
are problematic where somebody's messed
up a little bit or overplayed their hand
and I don't really have much like that
in this book The Great guide
by beginning there's only one thing that
I picked out for myself where I'm like
yeah I'm not sure I completely buy that
interpretation and this is where
um beginning
is saying to us that hume's work is more
indebted to Aristotle than you would
think and so what's the case that he's
making he's saying he was able to read
you know Aristotle's uh various works
and the metaphysics and Nick and McCain
ethics strangely however Hume barely
mentions Aristotle in any of his
writings in fact he only mentions the
great philosopher a handful of times
usually to take issue with his
metaphysics once to cite his list of
manly virtues and wants to correct him
on a point of human psychology
this only small the only small concealed
acknowledgment of his debt to Aristotle
is his Mark that a do medium says the
parapathetics is the characteristic of
virtue so the peripatetics are
aristotelians and in Humes day the word
was used to refer primarily to the
philosophy of the master himself the do
medium is the doctrine of the mean this
asserts that virtue is not the opposite
of a single Vice but lies somewhere
between the two extremes of Vice you
know so for example generosity between
meanness and pro prolificacy right and
he goes on and says you know Confucius
developed almost the same concept
completely independently
I think this is kind of a really
watered-down version of the Aristotelian
mean which we know is much more robust
than just as Hobbs said a mediocrity of
passions right and I don't think we have
to go too far to
find an explanation of why Hume isn't
really talking about Aristotle much
Aristotle and the aristotelians for most
early modern philosophers who aren't you
know Catholics has been largely
dismissed by that time it's not until
the 19th century that we see a massive
Resurgence in interest in Aristotle who
are the the 18th century philosophers
really interested in you know the people
that Hume writes about in his four
essays the stoics the epicureans the
Skeptics uh the platonists and of course
the person who Hume cites all the time
Marcus Tulia Cicero right Aristotle is
not really on their map so much so I
don't think that that bikini is is right
about that but I don't think he's like
totally wrong either so I did find that
little aspect of the work problematic
but I don't have much else to say that's
critical or let alone negative about
this text I'll even say too it's kind of
the right length it could be longer any
book can be deeper on its topic when
it's a great topic but I think this is
just the right size
all right so final thoughts about this
book as I said at the very beginning I
have zero reservations or qualifications
whatsoever in strongly recommending that
you acquire and read this this
particular book I I know I'm going to
keep it and re-read it because I think
it's pretty pretty good you know and it
would be interesting to see uh people
trying to apply
these very maxims about the work
I'd be curious to know if how how bikini
himself views that sort of stuff but
that's probably a topic for another day
so final thoughts great book check it
out get a copy at your library or
purchase a copy and you I learned things
about David Hume as somebody who's been
studying and teaching him for now
decades I learned some stuff from this
well-researched volume of beginning gave
me plenty to think about I think it
probably would be the case for you as a
reader as well